also das ist richtig beschrieben wenn
das so weiter geht werden sie die
innenstädte vieler städte und gemeinden
nach der korona krise nicht mehr
wiedererkennen
deswegen plädiere ich auch für eine
vorsichtige öffnung meine prognose am 5
januar werden die ministerpräsidenten
und die kanzlerin entscheiden dass das
bis 30 januar verlängert wird aber dann
brauchen wir zusätzlich eine strategie
wie wird wann wo gelockert das ist eine
erwartungshaltung der menschen was sie
beschrieben haben ist völlig richtig
wenn sie in einem kreis oder einer stadt
zwanzig oder dreißig oder vierzig
neuinfektionen haben dann sehen die
leute nicht ein warum sie nicht
einkaufen sollen also wir müssen viel
langfristiger denken und stadt immer zu
sagen jetzt kommt es noch härter ich
glaube ich dass es wichtig ist die
schnelltests strategien auszubauen nicht
nur im altenheim in der schule im
kindergarten das ist aus meiner sicht
ein viel vernünftiger weg und ich bin
hoffnungsvoll dass die politik diesen
weg auch gehen wird